[Music] really cool atmosphere I
mean obviously incredible stadium
and uh just can't wait to get out there
it's going to be a lot of fun you look
sick oh my God he almost killed
[Music] someone that's pretty good that's pretty
good that Sun's right in my ass Marley I Flip Flip
him flip I mean I just tried to get as many
pucks as I could to go over the glass I had
Stevie shooting some pucks and flipping high
like high flip see what the puck looks like
when it kind of goes up into the sky obviously
not used to that so just getting that di in for
tomorrow that's crazy love
that super pumped yeah it should be a lot
of fun and uh hopefully we can get a big
win